now back now to the latest cdc guidance
that agencies saying that
those who are fully vaccinated do not
need to wear a mask or practice social
distancing for the most part
but it's still urging people on the
screen you see to mask up in crowded
indoor spaces like
public transit or if you have covet
symptoms dr marty mccary fox news
contributor professor johns hopkins sir
how you doing good morning to you help
take us through this what should we
understand about it
now well they are trying to simplify
guidance by simply saying if you've been
fully vaccinated live
a normal life without any restrictions
except in transportation settings
but remember this comes in the context
of a lot of complicated restrictions
that are still in place
unvaccinated people are still told to
wear masks outdoors by the cdc that
makes no sense
the camp guidance makes no sense for
summer camps and kids are still shut out
of school so
this is one baby step and it comes about
three months late
the camp guidance was if you're a kid
you're playing soccer in july you still
have to wear a mask
i don't get it i i mentioned this quote
from dr rolinski from march
29th about impending doom just roll this
a second here
seven weeks ago watch i'm going to
reflect on the recurring feeling i have
of impending view we have so much to
look forward to
so much promise and potential of where
we are
and so much reason for hope but right
now i'm scared
she said it what changed
well look the numbers are way down
they've plummeted and the reason we got
this
announcement from the cdc yesterday all
of a sudden out of the blue without any
sort of
warning was that cases are down so much
more than the cdc anticipated because
they've been ignoring natural immunity's
contribution
to population immunity and that's why we
got this sort of sudden reaction
yesterday
okay here is randy weingarten you've
been listening to her right head of one
of the largest
teachers unions in america she has been
resistant for months
she changed her mind yesterday too watch
conditions have changed we can
and we must reopen schools in the fall
for in-person teaching learning
and support and we must keep them open
fully and safely five days a week
i said it earlier it's like flipping a
switch doctor
well i you know i think that a lot of
this is rhetoric because it's a hope
it's
what they aspire to and when it comes
down to it they've said that all along
they said
we've hoped and our plan has been to
have in-person learning but what they've
been able to do
is postpone cdc guidance long enough
so the policy can outlive the reality
and that's what's happened unfortunately
by the way
the science the conditions may have
changed in terms of the case numbers
the science hasn't changed that was true
in the september
2020 report by the cdc showing that
schools were safe and a lot of this data
both on the
lifting masks among fully vaccinated and
on schools
was from the israeli study and that was
done in february so in a word you're
cool with all this right that's what i'm
hearing for you doc
you're good look it's a it's babies it's
a baby step forward and i'm good with it
okay doctor thank you nice to see you
have a great weekend